so let's say we have log base B of x
equals n what you want to do is you want
to change this into exponential form by
doing the inverse operation just like
when you work with squaring and square
rooting you know how those undo one
another or multiplying dividing adding
subtracting those are all in verses and
they reverse or undo or you know reverse
out of the process so if we look at some
graphs here y equals 2 to the X this is
an exponential graph see how it grows
faster and faster and we have y equals
log base 2 of X you can see this graph
is growing slower and slower but notice
that these two graphs they're inverses
of one another the reflections over the
line y equals x ok so if we understand
that concept that exponential functions
and logarithmic functions are inverses
of one another we can use that to our
advantage so in this particular just
generic example this is log base b of x
equals n so the inverse of taking the
log base b is to exponentiate both sides
using base B now exponential functions
and logarithmic functions these are
inverses as long as the bases are the
same they're gonna undo one another so
we end up with here ax equals B to the N
okay let's look at some examples and
I'll show you how this works so in this
first example log base 3 of 9 equals 2
this is a true statement all we're going
to do is we're just going to rewrite it
so for example here what we're going to
do is we're going to exponentiate using
base 3 these are inverses and now you
can see that 9 is equal to 3 squared
which is which is of course true we've
just rewritten it in exponential form
let's look at this example here we've
got log base 5 of 125th equals negative
2 so we're going to just do the inverse
of taking the log base 5 of this side
we're going to exponentiate or raise
both sides using the base 5 this is the
inverse operation and we get 125th
equals 5 to the negative 2 I've got